did you say is the difference in
personality types of the way that women
are portrayed in Indian cinema versus
American cinema
I think luckily perceptions are changing
a lot
and it's a lot of blending happening but
I am proud to say that even though in
Indian cinema women are portrayed in a
very traditional fashion in some movies
I think that is also great because it it
reflects an era that still exists in
some areas of India whereas the the
modern woman that's portrayed who is
similar to the Western woman that's the
changing diaspora so I believe that I
was like both things to co-exist and
that's what I try to do in my first film
production I just release my personal
production and I played sign of a
bilateral role where one of me was very
traditional and the other me was
extremely modern and westernized it
hasn't been released yet touching its
hundredth day in theaters day after
tomorrow
in India and it's called John Lima
side-by-side and how has it been
received how is the more radical side of
that character been received in fact it
was very
it was a shock to people to see me on
that side because it's not just the
traditional but I play as a mycological
aspect of Indian cinema which is our
self transforming Cobra transforms into
this beautiful woman that's part of our
Lord in India so one of my goals was
that and it was kind of an unexpected
jolt that they received and I think it's
really well received because it's
touching its hundredth day it sounds
like a WoW now I know with Indian cinema
especially with Bollywood
you know stars are basically royalty
whereas in these states it seems like
they're definitely revered but not as
much so and with great power and a lot
of responsibility comes what type of
responsibility do you feel dear fans
because I'm sure on all the sites they
want to know what you're up to and and
everything what do you feel as a duty to
them in fact the funny thing is I have a
I would say dua like myself in real life
I'm a doctor as well so in that sense I
think my responsibility as well as a
responsible citizen of society is
already being fulfilled in my role as a
doctor and in real life and I took up
acting as a hobby and now it's turning
into almost a bilateral profession
because I loved the world of movies
so a responsibility yes I think just by
being a strong citizen who loves
humanity who wants to do good for
Humanity I don't think I need to be a
better example than that you know yeah I
think I think that's pretty much it now
don't you think that that grounds you so
much though because you're dealing with
medicine and all the things that you
know life and death that people are
facing that it really grounds you it
does and sometimes that's a negative
because I'm too grounded you know but on
the other hand I have so many very life
experiences as an emergency room
physician in the United States that I
can but that part of my soul which has
seen the the various extremes of human
life and death situations into the
intensity in my movies so I think I have
a little bit of an extra edge over many
of the other great actresses why I
really respect in a door but I like to
think I have a little extra edge because
it was extra life experience right and
lastly what do you say about the film
being banned for a few weeks back in a
coma huh since home town or actually in
India well I sure it is seen by everyone
because it is the world of cinema it is
a it is a world of entertainment it is a
world of just creating awareness you
know so
I really would like every film that is
made so well and not do with a stellar
stellar person such as command G I want
the whole world to see it and I sure
hope it gets cleared up
yes and I'm committed to seeing it
myself now very nice thank you very much
if we should